(cheerful piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- So let me talk about what we can learn
from congenital amusia.
First of all I'd like to
mention that we are all born
to be musical, and we all are.
That is musical engagement is ubiquitous,
and emerges early in life.
And that best evidence
is really that newborns
respond to abstract
properties of musical pitch
and time structure, like
changes in tonal key,
and disruptions of musical
beat, before the age of one.
They also move spontaneously to music,
and when moved in synchrony with music,
they show enhanced pro-social behavior.
So musical engagement is not only rooted
in social interactions,
but it is also a highly
pleasurable experience.
And I will illustrate it now with dance.
This is not the prototypical
musical situation,
but think of it, it's
really a musical activity.
And I'd like you to pay
attention to the first row
and the last one.
And these are the two extremes
I am really interested in.
(dance music)
And I'm sorry, but I will turn first
to the ones who don't have it.
That is, they represent
1.5% of the population,
and that's what I'm referring
to as congenital amusia.
I call it congenital
for the idea that it is
present from birth.
It defines a likely time
period, not the etiology.
Although, we have made a lot
of progress regarding this.
What's characterizing them,
it's the inability to detect
when someone sings out of
tune, including themselves,
to recognize and sing a
familiar tune without the aid
of the lyrics, and then to
maintain tunes in memory.
And what is really
fascinating is that it emerges
in isolation from other
disturbances, such as speech delay,
intellectual deficiency,
acquired brain damage
or even music deprivation,
they are exposed to music
like we all are.
And they have normal understanding
of speech and prosody
in everyday life.
It is also very similar to
other learning disorders
that you are familiar with,
like dyslexia, for example,
speech disorders like
the one we heard earlier,
dyscalculia, prosopagnosia.
And why are we so interested
by this condition?
It's because, it is a natural experiment
of the neurobiological origins of music.
Because it is an accident of nature,
we didn't create it, it
is a rare chance to link
brain, behavior and genes.
And also breakdown patterns
reveal how the brain works,
and I will try to illustrate
each of these points
in a moment.
But I have to tell you how we do that.
So we go from the behavior
to, and I will illustrate it,
so that you have an idea what it is,
from a functional explanation
to the brain correlates,
what are the anomalies in the brain,
to the etiology from the genes,
or the environmental factor.
And I will illustrate it with
someone who just wrote a book
about his condition, Tim Falconer.
He was 54 when he came to visit my lab,
and that's where he
discovered that he was amusic,
because he only had one
complaint, to sing out of tune.
And I really invite you to read his book,
which is a fascinating description,
because he writes so beautifully as well,
and has a very good sense of humor.
It just appeared last year.
But let me illustrate
it with his condition,
because we filmed him several times.
So typically they fail
to detect pitch deviancy.
Like here, there are two
melodies, and we ask them
if it is the same or different.
(melody playing on piano)
(melody repeats)
- I'm gonna say that was different,
I think there was an extra pause in there.
(melody playing on piano)
(different melody playing on piano)
- Same.
- And you could see on the
face that he couldn't tell,
he couldn't detect them.
Now the best part.
So we play with the
melody, so that the melody
is one semitone apart
from the accompaniment.
This is really a disorder
related to pitch structure,
and they are insensitive
to this kind of change,
while newborns are sensitive to this,
they do perceive this change.
So let me play to you the first example.
And of course we don't ask non-musicians
if it's dissonant or consonant,
we just ask if it's
pleasant or unpleasant.
(classical piano piece)
- So like 10 is really pleasant? Uh ...
(dissonant classical piano piece)
(audience laughs)
- And typically we see everybody laughs,
I don't understand why.
(audience laughs)
And this is really the
problem with this condition,
they are unaware of what's happening,
they have no idea what is
wrong and what is correct.
And most of them sing out of tune,
and they are unaware of it.
Just because other people
tell them that they are,
you know a little bit off.
Like Tim, he's not really
off, as you will see.
- (Tim singing poorly but
with recognizable melody)
Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you,
happy birthday dear Mahela,
happy birthday to you.
- But what is really nice
is when we ask him to sing
on la la la.
- (Tim singing, melody
unrecognizable) La la la la la.
La la la la la la.
That wasn't even close. (laughs)
- He knows that he doesn't
know what the tune is,
but he's improvising.
As well as the whole family,
I'll give you an example later.
But what is really
interesting is this fact.
That, in terms, I mean
Tim must be average here.
Here are the amusics, we have
a large pool of 38 amusics,
and here are the control.
So each dot represents the
average of one subject.
Each syllable is really
analyzed syllable by syllable.
And as you can see they
do sing less in tune
than the controls.
100 cents means one semitone,
and this is the building block
of the tonal Western system,
it is two adjacent keys on a keyboard.
And as you can see, they are
indeed deviant in those terms.
But what is very fascinating
is that maybe they are
out of tune relative to
what they should sing,
but they are in key.
That is the intervals they are singing
are really in the key, or
at least as well as control,
they don't make so many
errors in those terms.
And what is very interesting,
that when they improvise,
like Tim, they really made fewer errors.
So the idea is that
really we should improvise
a little more.
And it is hereditary.
And I'll play just the mother,
but this is really a
signature of the whole family.
I just don't want this
to be later on YouTube.
- [Man] Elsie Falconer.
- [Elsie] (singing very
poorly) Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you,
happy birthday dear friend,
happy birthday to you.
- Not everybody does,
I mean that's fantastic
about this family, because
most of them are affected.
I mean these are the black shapes.
I mean most of them are.
Of course a few are spared, so we can say
it's not really in the
environment, it is in their genes.
And we knew it is really hereditary.
So if you have one
relative in your family,
or close relative, then
there are 30% chance,
or 10 times at least more
chance that you have a risk
for amusia, so it is heritable.
So we tried to identify what
are the genetic variants
of this condition, because
it had been so successful
for speech disorders.
And for the moment, it
has been without success.
The only thing I can say,
and still it is a negative finding,
that we have no evidence
of FOXP2 mutation.
(audience laughs)
So it's like finding a
needle in a haystack,
but we will continue,
because I really think that
this is worthwhile,
because it has been found
for speech disorders,
and likewise I believe
that it may provide new entry
points to the neurobiology
of learning disorders in
general, not just amusia.
And to do so, what is
very important is to know
what's happening in the brain.
And we do know a lot about
the neural correlates
of this disorder.
Because it is a cortical disorder.
Here, back to Tim, we measured
the arcuate fasciculus,
this is a major fiber tract,
I should illustrate on the
right side of my brain,
that relates the auditory cortex
to the inferior frontal cortex
on the right side of the brain.
And as you can see, Tim here is in red,
and it's much smaller than a control
illustrated here in blue.
But of course you can do
that across many different
amusic cases and you
compare that to controls,
and it has been found in
many different studies,
that they do have a connectivity issue.
So the main problem with their brain
is a reduced connectivity
between these two regions,
the auditory cortex and the
inferior frontal cortex.
And it is really in terms
of functional anomalies
as well as structural anomalies.
We do find structural anomalies
in the auditory cortex
and the inferior frontal cortex
by having more gray matter,
but it doesn't seem to lead
to deficits in functioning.
And so a working hypothesis
explanation of the disorder now,
at least it's mine, it is in
terms of recurrent processing
between the auditory cortex and
the inferior frontal cortex.
And the idea that they do
have an intact representation
of musical pitch in the auditory cortex,
so the bottom-up information
is reaching their brain,
but they have poor
feedback control between
the right inferior frontal
cortex and the auditory cortex,
so the top-down aspect.
This is illustrated here.
So the information is
reaching the auditory cortex
correctly, but it is really this loop
that is malfunctioning in their case,
so that the auditory cortex
is really encapsulated,
it's not influenced by the
way they are processing,
or wanting to process.
So let me just illustrate
that with EEG recordings.
We did use different
neural imaging techniques,
but this one is really the
most revealing in this aspect.
So we presented melodies like these ones,
and asked them is there an incongruity?
So the first one.
(melody playing on clarinet)
Usually say that's fine.
That there is an incongruity,
if you are not amusic,
otherwise there is no
overlap in distribution.
So these are the amusics,
and these are the controls.
Each bar represents one subject.
But what was really fascinating,
and it has been replicated later on,
is that we found a negative,
early negative response,
in the brain of amusics
as well as controls here.
And while we only found a P600,
that means that they are
consciously detecting the deviance,
the pitch deviance, accompanied by a P600,
only in controls and never in amusics.
So we have a clear signature
here of what's going on
in their brain.
The auditory cortex, which
is really responsible
for the N200, is
responding to the deviance,
but it's not integrated consciously.
And it's not a problem of attention
because we have designed a situation where
we controlled for attention.
In this case, it was a
click they had to detect.
We replicated the same findings.
So this explains why, I
believe it is a question
of intact bottom-up information,
because the N200, also called
ERAN, or mismatch negativity,
seems to be replicated and
reflect this bottom-up processing
while the feedback revealed
by the P300 or P600
reflects poor control
between the right inferior
frontal gyrus and the auditory cortex.
And it is really a pitch
awareness disorder,
because it's really so high level.
Pitch regularities of
tonal music are registered
and predicted by the
auditory cortex of amusics,
without leading to conscious report.
And what is really missing
is a normal feedback loop
to learn from errors.
And it seems that really
error correction requires
intention and/or awareness.
So to summarize, what have we learned
from congenital amusia?
Here are only the things,
currently that I think
are the most important.
First of all, conscious
error correction is a really
fundamental principle of
how the human brain learns,
and we are not always conscious of the way
we correct ourselves, of
course, during learning
and when we are very young.
Also, functional specialization can emerge
from distributed brain networks.
It's no longer the case that
you can think of the brain
like really focal brain regions,
it is a distributed neural
network, as I have illustrated.
And a developmental anomaly
can disconnect the nodes
of a network and give rise
to severe yet specific
learning disorders.
And finally, the right
fronto-temporal connectivity
seems to be essential to develop
a normal cognitive system for music.
But I'd like to finish,
to end on a positive note.
Because I'm interested in those ones too,
that is the ones who dance so well.
And this is really
something we are starting,
studying what I believe
is the other extreme,
the high end of the spectrum,
those of the musical prodigies.
And I'd like just for
you to listen to a young
Indian prodigy, like this
one, at the age of nine,
and now we decrease.
(boy drumming)
And it goes on for five hours.
(audience laughs) It does, it does.
And here at the age of four.
(boy drumming, woman singing)
And at one year, I mean before speaking.
(boy drumming)
He has support for sure,
but I'd like to understand,
how is it possible to have
this kind of performance.
So I do consider them
as congenital anomalies,
happy ones, of course.
And because there are
recent findings showing
that really genetic
endowment is more predictive
of musical achievement than the
number of hours of practice,
that even the propensity
to practice appears
to be under a genetic influence.
(audience laughs)
You laugh, but this is a
result of a large sample
of twins study.
And the learning outcomes can be predicted
by the preexisting structural
and functional brain features.
So I'm afraid if you're not a
prodigy, you may not have it.
So musical prodigies provide
really an ideal paradigm
for investigating the
neurobiology of musicality,
and that's to which I'm
now turning for the future.
So I hope in maybe 10 years
from now to give you a key,
or the code of something
of access, of entry points,
to this special talent.
So thank you for your attention.
(applause)
(upbeat music)